a superpower is a country that has the
ability to project power globally both
economic political diplomatic
technological and soft power cultural
power and in that regard there's really
only one country in the world that is a
superpower today and no one else is
remotely close and that's the United
States as a superpower we we have known
historically when the Soviet Union was
around we knew very clearly what role we
should play we were making the world
safe for democracy we were in charge of
a global economic order we led the
process of globalization we created a
global internet global standards around
governance global institutions like the
WTO the World Bank the United Nations I
mean all of that after World War two
when we were the only country left
standing that was the role that America
played as a superpower and that really
existed for about a half a century of a
geopolitical order that was quite
dangerous but quite stable now when the
Soviet Union collapsed we've experienced
about 25 years of a geopolitical
environment that is much more unstable
though not particularly dangerous and
and over the course of that period
America's role has become more uncertain
US foreign policy has been more reactive
more risk-averse and we haven't talked a
lot about doctrine certainly not very
much about strategy well here we are in
2015 the geopolitical environment is
both unstable and getting very dangerous
we have failed States across the Middle
East we have the most powerful terrorist
organization the world has ever seen we
have more refugees than at any point
since World War two we have the Russians
invading a sovereign state and telling
us they don't care what the consequences
we might meet against them will be and
we have the Chinese increasingly
asserting themselves economically all
over the world to challenge a us-led
order and yet the United States does not
know what its
four Americans really do not know we
know where the superpower but we don't
know what it means we don't know what
our purposes we have an existential
crisis and perhaps more worryingly our
allies have the same thought when I talk
to foreign ministers around the world of
whether it's Singapore or Canada whether
it's Great Britain or Germany whether
it's Israel or Saudi Arabia I'm hearing
countries that are saying what do you
want what do what do you stand for can
we count on you
should we be hedging our relationships
with other countries and they are doing
that indeed so here we are in 2015 and
the United States is the world's only
superpower we are clearly not in decline
and yet our foreign policy influence is
absolutely in free fall and that's
abundantly clear from what we're seeing
transpire around the world I think
American foreign policy is in the
critical state that it is in part
because the Americans are less
interested in playing the role that we
have historically you know some of that
is three trillion dollars in wars in
Iraq and Afghanistan that we're seen to
be very very badly managed part of it is
an energy revolution and a food
revolution that means that we don't
really need we don't depend economically
on other parts of the world unstable
parts of the world the way we used to a
part of it is the United States with
mechanisms with tools of power like
cyber surveillance and like drones and
the weaponization of Finance using the
dollar as a stick to compel other
countries do what we want though all of
those policies don't require an awful
lot of coordination with allies we can
do it ourselves I mean ask Angela Merkel
if she thinks we need her for cyber
surveillance right you know it's it's
not NATO right it's a lot more what's
happening in Washington what we feel
like doing and it's not all about the
u.s. a lot of it is also about allies
that are less capable less willing
certainly in Europe we're seeing a lot
of that in the Middle East we're seeing
a lot of that
and it's also about a Russia which is in
decline and a Russian leader who really
wants to subvert a u.s. order and it's
about a China that's absolutely not in
decline it's resurgent it will soon be
the largest economy and they're getting
much more assertive about their
willingness to challenge America
economically and our ideas and
principles economically so definitely it
is becoming a top agenda item that that
US foreign policy is very much in
decline